[Music]
[Music]
how excited are you madam
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
over the weekend the small town of
Madras Oregon so its population swell
from 6,000 to more than 100,000 people
it's prime viewing location is why we
came here to beat the crowds we had to
get an early start
[Music]
I'll wait to Madras right early in
deserts in Oregon it's right on the path
of the solar eclipse and many tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
perspective so journey that should take
us only about an hour but the organizers
are told us to leave between six and
nine hours of the journey
[Music]
well that was much easier journey than
we were anticipating actually either
because people are already here as you
can see or because people are put off by
the weather there are some concerns
about forest fires and the smoke from
those and whether or not that will
impact on the eclipse or we're just here
in good time let's see
with the day's first sunrise you could
sense the excitement here we go we are
starting to get ready for nature's most
natural phenomenon in order to view the
Eclipse you need to be prepared you're
not looking at those are prophets and
their glasses those that they have you
seen a solar eclipse before No ok so
what it what are you most expected
because party some people scream some
people cry some people are crying
[Music]
some people can't articulate sentences
talk to you thanks Adrian tell us about
your telescope if can I ask you about
that I don't want to touch it because I
know it's very expensive and very
precious I need to stand next you
because you were using my microphone
alright this is basically it's a
Newtonian reflector basically the light
comes in here there's a mirror down in
that end comes the stack there's another
mirror at an angle that puts the
lighthouse through the eyepiece over
here of course I have a selector on it
right now because you should never ever
look at the sudden telescope it up
filter on it because that's what's going
to happen no this is this is kind of the
default direction it's actually pointing
North right now okay okay the way this
is set up you you aim this north and
then it will rotate as the Earth turns
the telescope will turn with it so it's
always plenty at the same place okay and
we're expecting clear skies so it looks
as though it's going to be a good view
looks pretty good look forward to it
thanks appreciate it thanks a lot how
are you your ex Isis what are you most
looking forward to
and I'm going to get a walk yeah why you
and what about when you're looking up in
the sky a little bit later on
as kind of like this guy's like woo I
know him but it's not gonna be though is
it's gonna be very dark and you're gonna
be able to see the Sun behind the moon
just the very outline of it do you know
what that's cool yeah because the Sun
comes up yeah and then W comes out and
then like the moon like goes down like
that the Sun can go bright no yeah
because because that one is there yeah
the moons in the way isn't it Mike
karaokes is an eclipse chaser and he is
presently in Illinois for us hello to
you Mike what's the appeal tell us
what's the appeal Oh what I mean if you
haven't seen one already you don't know
what's in sorry it's still hard for me
to grasp that in four hours we're gonna
be experiencing totality and the magic
of it feeling like you're in outer space
but without a spacesuit you're on the
moon you're seeing the Sun in this glow
this light and with all this colors and
all that detail and the dynamism of it
moving because you're actually seeing
the real movement of the moon and you're
seeing the sparkles of Baily's beads
diamond ring so it's a real-time
astronomical effect the grandest of all
ask Tom about acts that affects
everything around you all the atmosphere
red horizon all around shadows white
animals react temperatures drop so it's
it's some experience that we cannot to
get anywhere else let's look at what
causes a total eclipse it's down to a
couple of strange coincidences the
diameter of the Sun is four hundred
times wider than the moon's but the Sun
is also around 400 times further away
from the earth than the moon this means
that viewed from Earth they appear to be
the same size creating the stunning
effect of a total eclipse as the entire
surface of the Sun is obscured by the
moon when this happens those on earth
within the path of totality are plunged
into sudden darkness by the moon's
shadow
experiencing a total eclipse this makes
it possible for them to see the
spectacular phenomenon of the sun's
outer atmosphere bright rays of light
the corona and so much can be studied
about the Sun while this effect is
happening people keep talking to you
about elliptical orbits making for
variance what on earth does that mean it
sounds like a Telegraph crossword close
to me it basically is the dance between
the the earth the moon and the Sun the
questi moon goes around the earth and
the earth goes around the Sun and
certain periods of time is just right
that the moon is just the right distance
in just the right size but away from us
that it can actually block out the
bright disk of the Sun the thing about
it is it doesn't happen all the time
because the moon's orbit is slightly
tilted that's that elliptical orbit
mechanics that you were talking about
and therefore it's certain times the
shadow passes either side of the earth
but here today in just the right time it
just like this that sort of falls across
the United States but we're very
fortunate here that the winner is just
the right distance away but a book said
to break this to show us the beautiful
khulna as we'll see it today I'm
extremely excited how excited should I
be oh very excited this this kind of
thing has not happened for a very long
time but last time there was a
significant eclipse over a big part of
the continental United States was 1979
so this doesn't happen that often I'm
told that you're the first-ever
astronauts of video and eclipse is that
right right during my Space Station
mission from 2004 to 2005 I was alerted
about eclipses and I was able to get a
video camera and take some footage of
the event and it was pretty impressive
you know you saw a dark spot over the
clouds that got lighter towards the edge
but I have to tell you and it's one of
those astronomical events that's
actually more impressive from the ground
you can't say that about very many of
these astronomical events
this is the first set of clips truck
travel coast-to-coast in almost a
century as it began its journey across
the United States
millions turned their eyes to the sky
Oregon the first state in its path just
starting to buy it to the top right hand
side
then the magic began
[Music]
how excited are you madam 20% I'm not
sure it's 20% sure just looks like a
little nipple to me at the moment
have you sold it to the kids how we
thought we surprised them a year ago
when we booked the space here so we've
been playing this for a year okay okay
and what would be what what would be the
epitome for you what what are you most
looking forward to obviously seeing
Bailey speeds and the corona yes Baily's
beads would be awesome to see the edges
of the moon okay super excited that the
NASA people were wonderful explaining
everything to us this week
oh my goodness about 50% gone now I'm
gonna say
it's got a whole series of telescopes on
it yeah and so that we can switch back
from one scope to the other during the
totality I'm most interested in totality
okay no partial eclipses are cute but
it's not like the fabulous effective to
tell what's the difference for you
between totality and hospitality is like
it's unreal you have you have a sunset
all the way around you 360 degrees the
Stars the bright stars are out we're
actually clearing out the smoke a little
bit too and it's absolutely gorgeous
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's almost here it will last for
approximately two minutes and we'll be
able to take off our glasses and then
I'll let you enjoy that moment with us
in just a second people are counting us
down I thirty seconds to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a second sunrise of the day
oh my god it was
[Music]
NASA experts were out and up in force P
up over at the Pacific Ocean off the
coast of Oregon it was amazing wasn't it
I'd rather me like you know I have 25
years I did research on the corona I saw
it for the first time it was my first
Eclipse was it your first ago my first a
good as well absolutely amazing
[Music]
38,000 feet above the Pacific Ocean a
chaser charter flight caught the moment
there's a diamond ring gorgeous my 12
total eclipse and it was every bit as
good as that any eclipse I've seen no
one's out there protesting this eclipse
I mean it's really a perfect event for
the times and frankly if it reminds
people that our our existence is a lot
bigger than the planet that we're on
that's a good thing nature sends us
reminders every once awhile that we're
not alone as a planet we have neighbors
and this is a stark reminder and in a
very spectacular fashion strength
from the balcony of the White House US
President Trump took time to look up
we still have inside the feeling from
thousands of years ago when we didn't
know that the Sun wasn't being eaten by
a monster or a dragon and the very fact
that you see this black hole in the sky
where the Sun was brings out not only a
thrill but also something very visceral
something very profound and Biblical
inside you
when it just began it sort of sparked
and on one side and then everything went
dark and you can see the halo it just
kind of tickled yeah and all over it was
wonderful wonderful and I wish I could
do it again but I won't ever see
something like that ever again the 70
mile wide shadow traveled across the
u.s. in one hour and 34 minutes
[Music]
twelve million people live within the
path and another seven million a thought
to have traveled to the area right now
you can see that hazy ring that is the
chromosphere it is looking a little bit
sort of reddish
even where cloud obscured the view
crowds still cheered
[Music]
the go anymore world to see that exhibit
for you've got the experience cool
that's just all there is to
I'm so glad I was here for this like I'm
so lucky because being like in totality
like the last stop kind of of the United
States was amazing
giraffes run in circles nothing goes
flop together sooo keepers weren't
certain whether it was the Eclipse or
the excitement of the visitors that
affected their behavior the
International Space Station was outlined
against the Sun as the moon began to
cast its shadow well I'd seen pictures
from previous Eclipse and so I think I
had underestimated what this would look
like this was much darker than I gave it
credit for being for us you know the
witness said from above was just really
special because it represents how far
we've come with the technology we had I
mean look at we're on the International
Space Station where we're doing you know
more than 250 different experiments and
working with an international team look
at where we're at yes on a cruise ships
and along with Bonnie Tyler
[Music]
come on
yeah you may kiss your bride and a
couple shared vows uniting them during
the moment of totality what a beautiful
moment well that's at the end of the
solar eclipse 2017 it went straight
across the United States 200 million
people had the opportunity to view it
live
[Music]
centuries in the making
[Music]
decades in the planning
[Music]
minutes and it's magnificent
[Music]
[Music]
you